[Música]
[Aplausos]
hace tiempo
alguien me preguntó que se necesitaba
para llegar a donde estoy me pregunto
qué cuál era la fórmula del éxito en ese
momento no entendía que me quería
preguntar porque para mí como
emprendedor lo que importa es más la
trayectoria que el destino porque porque
la trayectoria donde tienes que innovar
adaptarte transformarte para que
cualquiera de las oportunidades que tú
tengas la convierta en una oportunidad
de hacer algo nuevo
convertir cualquier adversidad es el
momento donde tienes que transformarte y
entender que esto no lo haces por un
trabajo que ser emprendedor es un estilo
de vida vas a vivir diferentes tipos de
roles la gente conoce muchos roles de mí
pero tal vez no conocen el rol en donde
duermes únicamente cuatro horas al día
en donde vives en aeropuertos en donde
no ves los primeros pasos de tu hija en
donde estás lejos de tus amigos pero
también hay otras satisfacciones como
estar parado aquí enfrente de todos
ustedes
hola soy arturo martínez tura estoy
vestido con este atuendo por el que me
ha acompañado durante 10 años de carrera
hacia todos personas en 2009
hace casi 10 años y medio cuando un
grupo de amigos y nosotros decidimos
innovar en el mundo del entretenimiento
quisimos abrir un lugar para vender a
listas y cerveza
hoy en atendemos más de 800.000
comensales al mes
la gente me sigue preguntando cuál es la
fórmula del éxito de dar una fórmula
pero si les puedo contar unas historias
está dividida en diversos diversos pasos
que es lo que me ha traído aquí porque
existe un arturo antes de quedar la
empresa el momento en el que creé la
empresa en el momento que estuve a punto
de perder la empresa y el momento que es
el día de hoy porque esto no empezó hace
diez años esto empezó cuando vivía yo en
canadá cuando estaba trabajando de
ilegal cuando me dedicaba yo a bajar
manzanas a levantar tomates a recuperar
lombrices a vender piedras el año feliz
porque vivía el sueño canadiense hasta
que un día llegó la carta donde me
deportaron dijeron que tenía que
regresar
en ese momento fue mi breaking point fue
ese momento en el que no sabía que iba a
pasar pero sabía yo que tenía que buscar
una oportunidad para hacer algo
completamente diferente
y es entonces lo que empieza tal vez
esta parte de anécdotas y en los
diferentes puntos que les voy a ir
contando como el número uno que es el
soundcheck
porque está un chip porque en el sánchez
te permite si puedes equivocarte
puedes tener todos los errores que
quieras no tiene que ser perfecto es esa
etapa del mundo donde eres irreverente
donde no existe una autocrítica en donde
te puedes equivocar 1 2 3 4 veces
saben cómo consiguió el financiamiento
en esa época el 80 por ciento del flujo
de capital que nosotros metíamos era a
través de las casas de empeño
no había un lunes o martes que no
bajáramos las pantallas para llevarlas a
las casas de empeño obtener flujo de
capital y de trabajar y los señores no
me da vergüenza
pasado tres años y sabía que era momento
de crecer sabía que era el momento de
empezar a desarrollarnos y ahí pasamos
al punto número dos al baxter este punto
es súper interesante porque es el punto
en donde todos toman decisiones tras
bambalinas es el momento en donde
decides crecer o dónde decides parar
porque cualquiera de los que está aquí
lo puede decidir nadie conoce el negocio
como ustedes nadie conoce lo que están
haciendo como ustedes porque ustedes son
la esencia de lo que realmente hacen
en mi punto sabía yo que tenía que
crecer en el momento crecer y saben que
me atreví abrimos la segunda sucursal y
fue increíble
tuvimos un éxito rotundo que duró
únicamente 30 días
nos clausuraron
estábamos en el piso
alguien por ahí me dijo están
traspasando lugar en una de las avenidas
más emblemáticas de la ciudad
fui hablé con la persona que me estaba
traspasando eligió y me encanta que lo
quiero comprar
y me lo vendió usted va a decir cómo es
que lo compro si no tenía dinero es
exactamente eso era el rey del empeño
se empeña en mi marca y la tienda que
tenía
si yo en seis meses no le pagaban perdía
todo lo que tenía una unidad de negocio
que estaba trabajando y mi marca
me arriesgué me fui a fondo porque había
decidido que el riesgo era nuestra arma
hoy no me arrepiento
y haber puesto en peligro en riesgo a
todos los amigos que trabajan con
nosotros a todos los compañeros del
haber puesto en peligro la marca saben
por qué porque hay es una de sus
unidades más emblemáticas a nivel
nacional
a pesar de haber estado en pegada de ahí
salió y de ahí pasamos al paso número 3
este paso es súper interesante que éste
le llamo el back to basics ustedes van a
decir como to basics parecía que había
un camino trazado
parecía que todo indicaba hacia dónde
íbamos a ir muy pocas veces la gente
entiende que en el back to basics es
cuando tu negocio te empieza a hablar
uno como emprendedor no se da cuenta que
el negocio es un ser vivo déjenme
decirle que los negocios son seres vivos
son como seres humanos sienten tienen un
adn comparten viven vibran están con
ustedes están con nosotros y ellos son
los que te hablan y te dicen oye tú
arturo hay que seguir creciendo hay que
desarrollarnos
los negocios son seres vivos va a ver
etapas de esponjamiento también va a
haber etapas de pleito
nosotros decidimos ir en contra de lo
que decían en ese momento los
consultores y los libros porque la
verdad nos quisimos ir a 1200 kilómetros
de distancia de acá para poder aperturar
el negocio el libro decía que no
abriéramos a más de 200 pero el negocio
no les estaba pidiendo la esencia del
negocio no estaba viendo los vamos a
abrir a mérida que era una ciudad donde
nadie nos conocía sin embargo la ciudad
estaba ansiosa de un concepto como el de
nosotros me tocó vivir tres meses ahí
pasar la increíble entender el entorno
pero sobre todo saben qué fue lo que me
gustó que jamás perdió la esencia el
negocio
decidimos que el negocio no solamente
tiene que crecer de adentro hacia afuera
sino que puede crecer de afuera hacia
adentro imagínense que se están comiendo
sándwiches y se comen las orillas y
después el centro eso es lo que nosotros
hicimos al menos eso nos funcionó a
nosotros en esta anécdota de éxito
pasamos nos iba muy bien y esto nos dio
el brinco al cuarto paso que este es el
stroke
qué significará electrón porque el tipo
habla del slow the rock es ejecución
pero ejecución sin perder usted es su
estilo si ser quién son no se necesita
un proceso para ejecutar tienes que
hacerlo porque lo tienes que vivir lo
tienes que sentir y tienes que hacerlo
lo más rápido posible se acuerdan de los
tres primeros años que perdí en la etapa
del sound check imagínense si durante
esos tres años hubiera venido alguien me
hubiera ejecutado más rápido que yo si
se hubiera atrevido a tomar la decisión
más rápido que yo posiblemente no
estuviera aquí parado en frente de todos
ustedes posiblemente estuviera yo
escuchando la historia de alguien que
decidió vender cervezas ya listas y no
fuera yo
por eso ejecuten sin perder su estilo
háganlo no se necesita el tiempo simple
y sencillamente muevan se ejecuten
ustedes saben es en base a su instinto
nadie les pueda aconsejar mejor porque
ese instinto se que tienen ustedes y es
este disco duro donde tienen toda la
información guardada que les hace usted
es decir les flota o no les root
y entonces brincan a otro paso
en este paso dividen cual es one minute
en how
amo este paso
qué significa para mí notting hill todos
aquí hemos fracasado todos
y si no los invito a fracasar fracasen
es necesario fracasar es necesario
equivocarse es necesario cometer errores
a mí me encanta fracasar es algo que
hago todos los días voy por el camino
digo hoy voy a fracasar
de verdad da y se desprende el proceso
del fracaso nosotros lo tenemos
amarrados por el proceso de la felicidad
sabían ustedes que con la misma
felicidad con la que se abre un negocio
es la misma felicidad con la que lo
deben desarrollo
háganlo nosotros por ejemplo tenemos
marcas que hemos aperturado ya los 15
días de estar trabajando las hemos
cerrado he decidido que no va a vivir
más 15 días abierta al público llegamos
y decimos este negocio no funciona más
llamamos a toda la gente que trabaja
venimos la disfrutamos y la pasamos
increíble a veces hasta llegan los
familiares nos comemos todo lo que hay
cerramos pintamos y volvemos a trabajar
fracasen todos los invito a que fracasen
tú tú tú tú cualquiera fracasé es
necesario fracasar
y esto te lleva al otro punto porque no
vayan a decir este de falda me está
diciendo que nada más tengo que fracasar
hay una secuencia y se dan cuenta la
cronología de las anécdotas de la vida
ya que hemos fracasado vamos al
siguiente punto que es el punto profes
que significa roces es vivir todo el día
como si estuvieras en un festival de
rock y no llamemos el rock como la
música que escuchamos no amamos el rock
como el estilo de música llamemos el
rock como un estilo de vida como ustedes
lo quieran vivir como ustedes lo quieran
llegar a sentir
nunca tengan pena de sentirse orgullosos
de lograr triunfos
también se es humilde reconociendo el
triunfo y los logros obtenidos porque
muchas veces la gente tiene miedo de
triunfar mucha gente tiene miedo de
decir lo logré viva lo disfrútenlo como
un festival de música solamente háganlo
es ese momento en el que tienen que
disfrutar en que lo tienen que hacer y
decir estáis viviendo un festival de
música y lo tengo que lograr
imagínense si yo lo estuviera orgulloso
de eso
del concepto que tanto les he estado
platicando que empezó hace 10 años hoy
tenemos presencia en todo méxico
estamos en eeuu hemos entrado a
latinoamerica y queremos seguir
creciendo
pero saben que ahí es lo que me
interconecta con el otro punto que me
interconecta con el último punto de esta
historia de anécdotas
qué son los puntos del comenzó que
significa comenzó para este tipo
existe que no hay fórmulas secretas del
éxito
no hay una fórmula escrita que te va a
garantizar que va a triunfar
tú puedes empezar en el punto número uno
puedes empezar en el punto número 2
puedes empezar en el punto número 3
puedes estar en el soundcheck en el
backstage en el one minute girl pero la
cosa es que tú quieras empezar un ciclo
de tus propias anécdotas y de tus
propias historias para lograr el triunfo
tú lo tienes que hacer ahí me encanta
vivir la apertura me encanta reiniciar
me me encanta todos los días empezar de
nuevo y todos los días volver a
aparentar que estoy haciendo algo nuevo
no no aparentar vivirlo reinicien se
llega lo todos los días eso es parte
importante de todos estos pasos
hay gente que me pregunta por y por qué
lo estoy haciendo
mi motor hoy es toda la gente que
colabora con nosotros mi motor hoy es mi
país porque es un lugar que vende alitas
y chevy somos un lugar que está apoyando
y transformando nuestro país estoy casi
seguro que aquí entre toda la gente que
estamos existe un puñado de gente que
realmente quiere cambiar este país que
tiene toda la potencia toda la
creatividad y toda la imaginación para
lograrlo
ustedes son los que pueden hacer el
verdadero cambio
muchas gracias a todos y recuerden let's
rock
[Aplausos]